[Musique]
bonsoir messieurs dames bonjour donc on
va vous pas celle effectivement un
dessin voilà que j'ai réalisés pendant
la présentation des quatre premiers
speaker le thème de la journée c'était
le temps et vous allez voir que ce
n'était peut-être comme point de départ
et que d'autres thématiques ont été
abordées finalement tout d'abord donc
sandra nous a souhaité bienvenue avec
son équipe d'addicts à tedx et avec
cette speaker qui était prêt à donner le
meilleur d'eux mêmes des speakers
inspiré et inspirant de ce que j'ai
entendu la mission qui vous a été confié
c'est on va changer de paradigme et
rapidement on nous parle de réfugiés qui
feuilletait dicks c'est pas la première
idée qui nous vient en ce moment quand
on part de réfugiés c'est assez
incroyable
c'est à dire que ces gens là ils sont
tous linverse de nous c'est à dire que
leurs besoins primaires ne sont pas
satisfaits et leur premier réflexe c'est
de penser à s'élever sur cette
thématique effectivement des réfugiés
yves est venu nous parler d'une
civilisation qui est en danger
une civilisation ancienne qui va être
oublié perdu dans les mémoires de
l'humanité car elle recouvre de l'argent
finalement oui je sais vous allez drc du
cuivre mais vous m'avez compris et donc
ils ont mis en place un système de
drones comme vous l'aviez qui fait de
l'acquisition de photos et qui au
travers d'une ia va reconstruire des
mondes numériques
la question que je me suis posée c'est
est ce que le drone qui prend les photos
va être embêté par une drones d'attac
qui est là pour détruire effectivement
la civilisation
peut être qu'ils vont se disputer un
peut-être que le droit de yatta frère
c'est bon tranquille je me laisse
prendre des photos je bosse ça les
pousse toi post war est remarqué c'est
peut-être un vecteur d'espoir si on
laissait les problèmes on laisse les
robots régler les problèmes entre eux
peut-être que les gens en bas du gabon
bah écoute on les laisse se débrouiller
elles ont d'abord l'apéro on a discuté
et on va parler de notre histoire
commune
ouais c'est une vision d'espoir que que
je vous laisse nourrir donc on va
reconstruire des mondes numériques
la question que je supposais c est ce
que les ja prendront soin des mondes
numériques
c'est à dire est ce qu'avant de les
détruire ils mettront en place des
drones numérique voilà il y en a qui
salit voilà c'est
easy sont assez bons donc de quoi nous
parlons
yves de la reconstruction vous avez
entendu ce terme la destruction
moi j'ai entendu extinction comme si la
sixième extinction avait commencé goutte
après goutte bombe après bombe et donc
il nous parle de reconstruction avant la
destruction avant que l'on oublie mais
le monument dont il parle c'est pas
simplement les bâtisses c'est notre
mémoire et il nous dit comment nous
maintiendrons notre mémoire par la
culture au delà de la guerre c'est pour
ça que j'ai appelé finalement son nom
son intervention c'est l'apologie de du
monument mais qui est le monument de
notre histoire
qu'est ce que vous nous nous voulons
faire de notre histoire parce que
effectivement au bout d'un moment les
civilisations les monuments on ne les
voit plus comme les vieux c'est ce que
nous a dit serge vous rentrez dans une
maison de retraite les vieux vous les
voyez plus up parquet dans la salle télé
allez hop
donc ces personnes que l'on doit buffet
que nous sommes devenus invisibles
enfin ils nous sont devenus invisibles
de notre côté nous même des fois on ne
se voit plus vraiment alors nos vieux
vous comprenez c'est compliqué moi je
pense que quand il est question
d'histoire
ben à une époque c'était les profs qui
transmettait l'histoire mais non c'est
mr google mais c'est des vieux est ce
que finalement les vieux ne sont pas les
monuments de notre histoire
les piliers de notre civilisation
pourquoi on les parque comme ça là moi
c'est ce que j'ai retenu c'est que cette
maison de retraite elle porte en elle
effectivement les monuments de notre
histoire et ce qu'il nous propose c'est
une manière de vivre différentes
alors on peut revenir effectivement sur
le vivre ensemble
moi ce qui m'a intéressé c'est le je
suis un peu un psychopathe de la
sémantique et surtout de l'étymologie si
on décompose le mot
inter-générationnelle enlève inter on
aime le elle reste génération ne parlons
pas d'une génération mais de la
génération
le fait de générer c'est ça que nous
portons le potentiel d'action ce que
nous propose serge
c'est de croiser les générations pour
générer je laisse à chacun d'entre vous
de finir cette phrase parce que vous
avez sûrement chacun une vision
différente de ce que l'on pourrait
générer avec séjourna j'oublie un petit
point en bas ce que nous inviter à faire
serge c'était quand même le passage à
l'action il a fini en disant agir
maintenant tous ensemble pour ne pas
j'ai pas su quoi mettre sur moi je me
dis en fait ce dont ils nous battent
c'est de ne pas mourir seul
on a peur de mourir mais je crois que le
pire c'est de mourir seul
ces gens là meurent seuls voilà ça
c'était pour péter l'ambiance une bonne
fois pour toutes
donc dû d'entrée il est cash michel nous
parle de quoi de principes actifs sains
il nous parle de molécules super motivé
d'accord et ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'il nous dit qu'elles ont toujours été
là donc je vous ai mis des cases à
cocher ou cochon donc j'ai marqué les
molécules les anciens et les rampes
les réponses ont toujours été là je vous
laisse remplir selon vous laquelle de
ces réponses est juste ou lesquels ou
peut-être les trois mois ce que j'ai
entendu si on a tout sous la main
on a tous déjà depuis toujours on est
tout le temps en train de projeter dans
notre mental vers l'avenir vers le
lointain alors que tout est là et il dit
que lui la manière dont il travaille
c'est avec simplicité et bon sens et ça
ce sont des denrées éternelle donc est
ce que michel je vous dis qu'il faut
faire du neuf avec du vieux
non ce qu'il vous dit c'est qu'il faut
créer du présent avec de l'éternel
celle-là je suis fier
le prix nobel veut prix nobel de la
facilitation rappliquer pour moi je me
fatigue moi même ma compagne est là elle
peut vous dire elle est en dépression
voilà donc en fait il nous fait rentrer
vraiment dans le réel il a les pieds sur
terre la tête dans les étoiles
ça tombe bien parce que c'est connecter
avec l'intervention de audrey donc
effectivement il dit finalement il faut
arrêter de fantasmer lie à tous à
l'intelligence artificielle on est entre
la tarte à la crème et la mine d'or dans
la mesure où les ia peuvent inquiéter
mais pour l'instant elles sont limitées
c'est à dire que leur niveau d'action
effectivement est programmée avec des
autos décision mais sur un contexte
limitée cd fonctionnaires font tout
temps la même chose s'il ya des
fonctionnaires la pensée pour vous et
ali finalement qu'est-ce qu'on projette
au travers des liasses et nos peurs nos
peurs on est mort de trouille et surtout
on projette noguier c'est à dire que
nous sommes les humains qui créons des
ia et inconsciemment on projette tout ce
qu'il y en ait le bon je vous laisse
lire cette phrase sans discours
finalement ce que si je pu l'interpréter
c'est d'arrêter de chercher à
l'extérieur dans d'autres systèmes
mon interprétation de la cette fois
c'est ce qu'on n'est pas capable de
s'emporter soi même comment est ce qu'on
peut qualifier un moment où tel que
celui ci
parce que là je sens qu'on est tous sur
la même énergie voyez on est tous là
c'est à dire un moment où on est dans
une bulle dans une forme énergie ou des
gens qui ne se connaissent pas se
réunissent un moment chargé d'émotion
mais l'émotion pas dans l'affect une
émotion dit ça y est c'est bon cette
fois c'est sûr je change
je vais faire le pas de côté vous savez
ce genre d'incident était hyper puissant
parce qu'on dit c'est bon je le fais et
à la fois fragile comme du crystal parce
qu'il suffit de recevoir un texto et de
retourner dans notre tempête mental
comme ça peut arriver juste au moment de
la pause pour que ce moment s'effondre
de mon point de vue ce moment où des
gens se réunissent comme vous chargez
d'énergie où le mental est vide on est
juste connecter sur ça y est je vais le
faire ce moment là je qualifierais ça
d'un moment de grâce mais mieux
je pense que là ce que nous vivons là ça
va se terminer dans trois secondes c'est
un moment d'éternité
merci beaucoup monsieur dame
[Applaudissements]